[Music]
good evening I'm Bret Baier we're coming
to you live tonight from the White House
as the administration deals right now
with reaction to President Trump's
announcement a few hours ago hear that
the u.s. is withdrawing from the Iran
nuclear deal as a candidate of course
mr. Trump campaigned hard on a promise
to get the u.s. out of a deal he called
horrendous and one-sided
as president he labeled the agreement
ridiculous and insane his political
opponents and European allies say he has
no real plan that they've seen going
forward chief White House correspondent
John Roberts starts us off here on the
North Lawn with a massive global story
yeah John certainly isn't one that we've
been expected for a long time to breath
where we go from here is uncertain but
one thing that is for sure just about
everybody who has an interest in this
has something to say about it it was a
move a long time coming
president Trump had vowed in the
earliest days of the campaign to scrap
the Iran nuclear deal today he did it it
is clear to me that we cannot prevent an
Iranian nuclear bomb under the decaying
and rotten structure of the current
agreement the Iran deal is defective at
its core the announcement brought a
sharp reaction from Iranian president
Hassan rouhani who said Iran would
immediately begin negotiations with
America's European allies China and
Russia to save the deal adding if they
couldn't reach agreement Iran will start
enriching uranium quote more than before
in the coming weeks President Trump
today warned Iran not to go down that
road if the regime continues its nuclear
aspirations it will have bigger problems
than it has ever had before the
president made the decision despite
pleas from France the UK and Germany to
stay in the deal in a joint statement
the three nations saying we urged the
u.s. to ensure that the structures of
the jcpoa can remain intact and to avoid
taking action which obstructs its full
implementation by all other parties to
the deal president Trump's announcement
starts a countdown clock running 90 days
to the re-imposition of most sanctions
we will be instituting
the highest level of economic sanction
any nation that helps Iran in its quest
for nuclear weapons could also be
strongly sanctioned by the United States
America will not be held hostage to
nuclear blackmail we will not allow
American cities to be threatened with
destruction in a statement President
Obama called the decision misguided a
serious mistake saying it could embolden
an already dangerous regime threaten our
friends with destruction pose
unacceptable dangers to America's own
security and trigger an arms race in the
world's most dangerous region president
Trump insists the deal President Obama
helped craft allowed Iran to continue
down the path to a nuclear breakout
saying a nation the chance death to
America will never be allowed to possess
a nuclear weapon today's action sends a
critical message the United States no
longer makes empty threats when I make
promises I keep them Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer didn't support the
Iran deal but opposes the US withdrawal
saying Iran wasn't violating the
agreement plus what would president
Trump replace it with this is a little
like replace and repeal they had these
words they used them in the campaign and
they don't have a real plan here while
there is nothing at the moment to
replace the joint comprehensive plan of
action President Trump says he is
willing to negotiate a new deal one that
covers Iran's short term nuclear program
long term nuclear ambitions its
ballistic missile program and
destabilizing regional behavior the fact
is they are going to want to make a new
and lasting deal one that benefits all
of Iran and the Iranian people when they
do I am ready willing and able great
things can happen for Iran and great
things can happen for the peace and
stability that we all want in the Middle
East late this afternoon the Treasury
Secretary who I know you'll be speaking
with in just a couple of minutes
said that it is the intention of the
administration to get a deal with Iran
under the wind-down provisions of the
u.s. exit from the joint comprehensive
plan of action
Iran has 180 days to come to the table
right you know there may be a position
that Iran wants to renegotiate but boy
that wasn't the signal from these
European leaders that they weren't going
to or they weren't going to get any
indication from Iran to reopen talks
well that was certainly the position of
Iran but you know if you start to twist
arms maybe Iran has a change of heart
but the difference is that the president
wants to get a comprehensive deal on all
four of those pillars McCrone Merkel
Theresa May Boris Johnson was here
yesterday we're saying well let's leave
the jcpoa in place and negotiate a new
deal in those other three points but
that's not a gamble the president was
willing to take all right John thank you